je ferai ma finale
ce chiffre est
x leïla est d'aller
[Musique]
vous pouvez jouer avec nous par sms à
30,88 tombe bien vous appelez le 39 27
pour jouer avec nous et il y a
aujourd'hui à remporter jusqu'à 7500 40
euros je vais prendre que tu veux
quelqu'un qui va jouer avec moi depuis
peu dans le public bien sûr des chiffres
côté des cma c'est exactement la même
règle que le jeu d'hier les sauf qu'on a
changé le type pour faire actifs sur le
générique wilson d' arnaque mais on
kiffe et bien sûr s'il ya des chiffres
puisqu'il y aura une question chiffres
il ya bien sûr des remarques qui sont
ici tout autour de la table qu'il veut
jouer avec moi je vais prendre quelqu'un
je vais prendre une fille aujourd'hui
parce que j'ai pu bien venez madame
tenez voilà venez nous rejoindre
alors battre ensemble jouent également
j'ai voulu vous vous inspirez parce
qu'on va peut-être vous prendre dans un
instant que pour gagner beaucoup
d'argent 7540 euros bonjour bonjour
comment vous appelez dorothée vous êtes
très souriante très joli très
sympathique si j'adore c'est la couleur
fauve hautot ça oui ça normalement on
arrive comme ça on fait je veux une
foule je veux une faux je veux une auto
comment vous faites quoi dans la vie
je suis commercial commercial dans quoi
dans le transport transport très bien
que j'aime bien vos lunettes j'aime
d'abord il ya un truc j'ai sympathie l
envie de ce départ si elle est comme
nous elle est vraie vr et la famille et
les vrais de vrais cet arrière-plan
s'est marié avec qui ma classe me
charles c'est qu'elle omet charme au gas
on dirait jean luc lemoine
même genou en plus mon nom sympa mamers
il fait quoi horrifier il est retraité
mais attends mais il a 25 ans non non
non mais sans rigoler ou pas mais c'est
vrai retraités oui c'est le fait avec
une chaîne qu'il m'a assez sabam cas
merci d'être avec nous il ya beaucoup
d'argent à gagner vous venez d'où
soissons et rappelle qu'il y avait déjà
jeté un vase
[Applaudissements]
un petit peu d'histoire ne fait pas des
halles un petit peu de culture qu'est ce
qui se passe là bilan elle me dit
qu'elle me racontera l'histoire du vase
de soissons d'accord mersch a les jets
de situation s'était pas pour vous
particulièrement cette bague
attention on va jouer avec une première
question pour 30 euros dans la cagnotte
30 euros de plus vous avez 5 secondes
pour me donner une réponse c'est du vrai
faux à chaque fois hier soir lors du
meilleur pâtissier cyril lignac a
confondu une religieuse avec mercotte au
moment de la fourrer c'est faux à votre
avis alors et vous avez répondu bien sûr
je les reproduis vous avez tous répondu
faut bien entendu c'est faux hier soir y
avait le lancement de la septième saison
du meilleur pâtissier et on a retrouvé
donc julia vignali qu'on aime beaucoup
aux côtés de mercotte et cyril lignac
ça fait un véritable carton sur ce qu'on
appelle la femmes responsables des
achats
celle qui est la plus importante à la
télévision voilà je voulais vous dire
c'est vrai que c'était loin devant
c'était premier inventaire un cadre plus
de baignade % sur les femmes
responsables des achats
merci vous étiez la biblothèque à
regarder les scores hier alex hugo qui a
cartonné sur les conduisait vers les
mineurs le meilleur pâtissier des
racines et des ailes et burger quiz qui
arrivent vers un cinquième qui ai fait
pas mal à 840 milles des racines et des
ailes
c'est tout ce fait tous le même score
entre 2 millions et 2 millions d'oeufs
alors le meilleur pâtissier guerre si
vous avez manqué l'émission rassurez
vous on l'a résumé pour vous regardez
hier soir c'était le lancement du
meilleur pâtissier
on s'est tu as beau et oui un petit
débrief ça vous dit moi je suis partant
pour cette première les douze pâtissiers
amateurs ont fait leur rentrée des
classes
les enyele on a un petit garçon
l'occasion de découvrir un casting avec
des personnages forts
astrid 69 ans et accessoirement sosie
officiel de mercotte tu m'en rappelle
que c'est interdit d'antenne 2 à vannes
julien le plus jeune participant de
l'histoire de l'émission je m'appelle
julien j'ai 16 ans et je suis laissée en
combien russe david 44 ans alias l'homme
qui a la même voix que les mecs floutés
dans un interdit c'est bon ces croquants
fait pour man ou encore marianne est là
qui nous vient du costa rica
une jeune femme très sympathique même si
on comprend pas tout ce qu'elles disent
les dos
on est peinards polar evogene à la plage
un casting haut en couleurs pour des
gâteaux ou en couleur littéralement
c'est très bon moi je dis bravo parce
que tu as vraiment fait un bon marbre et
tu me fous la lumière oui c'est très
beau bref un bon casting et des beaux
gâteaux tous les ingrédients étaient
réunis pour un retour honorable
hier soir deux millions deux cent
soixante trois mille téléspectateurs ont
regardé le meilleur pâtissier pâtissier
[Applaudissements]
vous le sachet c'est le programme le
plus de cuisson dames 6 on ménage hier
actuellement même voilà avec l'amour est
dans le pré c'est un des problèmes de la
télé est un des plus puissants
le meilleur pâtissier kenny par exemple
dans le meilleur pâtissier ah oui je
suis né j'ai voulu regarder je déteste
la pâtisserie vraiment mais j'adore voir
cette émission donc chercheurs ont fait
rêver ça rigolo j'aime bien les faits de
compétition j'aime bien ce je vais
regarder quoi vous dire
yeah yeah